aux côtés des drapeaux des 28 lignes ou
jack faute encore au pied du parlement
européen les eurodéputés britanniques
n'en sont pas moins sur le départ je
suis très heureuse parce que maintenant
les gens vont vraiment voir que nous
avons franchi la première étape nous
avons techniquement quitter l'union
européenne et nous avons décidé cela il
ya déjà longtemps
donc c'est vraiment un soulagement dès
le 31 janvier le pays n'aura plus de
commissaire européen ni d'eurodéputés
plus de trois ans et demi après le
référendum
un point de non retour pour le chef de
file du bric site et opposant historique
à l'union européenne
nigel farrage le 31 janvier de melgven
nous quittons les union européenne pour
franchir un point de non retour
c'est sa toute l'importance de cette
semaine pour ce qui est de ce que cela
signifie pour nous sur le plan
constitutionnel de notre place dans le
monde
c'est probablement la chose la plus
importante depuis qu'henri viii qui nous
a fait sortir de l'église de rome
il nous a fait sortir de l'église
romaine et nous quittons le traité de
rome
il n'y a pas de retour en arrière
possible mais alors à quoi ressemblera
l'union amputé d'un de ses états membres
la perte sera d'abord démographique
l'union européenne verra partir plus de
66 millions d'habitants soit près de 13
% de sa population et plus de 15% de son
pib
sans les britanniques les mieux passera
en dessous de la barre symbolique du
demi milliard d'habitants avec 446
millions de personnes en son sein
l'union est également un membre
permanent au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu ainsi qu'une de ces deux
puissances nucléaires
le secrétaire britannique à la défense a
tout de même voulu rassurer ses
partenaires européens
le brésil ne remet en aucun cas en cause
les questions de sécurité de l'europe
qui est vraiment très important pour la
grande bretagne autant qu'elle l'est
pour l'état membre de l'union européenne
n'y aura aucun problème et je pense que
vous savez que nos relations bilatérales
on est en solide lorsque nous sommes
dans l'union européenne
et ce sera tout aussi fort après l'union
européenne deux jours avant cette sortie
historique
c'est une journée chargée en émotion qui
attendent des britanniques
le parlement européen vote aujourd'hui
pour sceller le traité de divorce dès le
31 janvier à 23h le royaume uni rentre
dans une période de transition jusqu'à
la fin de l'année pendant laquelle ils
continueront d'appliquer les règles
européennes
un laps de temps pour négocier la
nouvelle relation qu'entretiendrait à
londres et bruxelles